[Music]
in new york
the playground has become the
battleground
and for what cyphers all right cyphers
[Laughter]
we're [ __ ]
we're gonna work out our differences
through dance
that'll be tight uh the differences that
we're talking about
that's what he does oh [ __ ] you guys
[ __ ]
just practice taking around there taking
around the room do you guys figure out
uh instead of using contracts in the
court of law do dancers
tiff tiff have a dance off in the middle
gotta do one of the night
they're doing a wave that's being passed
all the way around
also very practical oh you're good huh
and then
and then i just like they call me my
song oh [ __ ]
damn oh it got stuck everybody went
through though it went through it went
through
you can always tell by that by the mouth
open
[Laughter]
you focus meanwhile
[Music]
lots of stuff happening there like pass
[Laughter]
all right here we go all right so in new
york city there is a new
uh fight between two sides uh fitness
freaks
and moms what what's happening right now
is that they're hugging up the
playground you can't hogging up the
playground yeah so moms of new york are
getting
angry at people taking up taking over
playgrounds
and working out there and uh that's
[ __ ] rude
if you see a kid move out of the way
there's nothing
kids get priority what about the hot
fitness moms in the hot yoga pants
oh yeah what if you're on both sides at
the same time oh like your kid's playing
so you're getting a workout in but
they're the they're the mediators
they're the ones that
they're the middlemen middle woman get
out of my way kid and just
pulls them off the monkey party which is
like the part that we go to
like there's these really dope ass wings
and
every time like isaac and i will be
swinging or whatever but then i'll see
these little kids coming like oh come on
isaac
we're done swinging we're done swinging
it's for the children like that
it's literally for them
those kids don't pay to taxes we do
that's just mine first danny hello right
i know i'm like that's my slide if i
want to get on that [ __ ]
yo you wait your turn until you become
adult and start paying for this [ __ ]
the parents are paying for taxes you're
[Applause]
alright
damn you're right i'm on the mom's side
you're right true
uh so i'm actually on the mom's side and
on the fitness i'm like ah they've
always got really good
compelling arguments arguments here's
the thing the game
i'm already gonna solve this how are we
gonna solve it
all right check this out kids shouldn't
be
out after dark any [ __ ] way right
true so after 5 pm fitness dudes
get to play they close the parks too and
fitness people are morning people
then don't and then well people can go
at yeah come in at 4 00 a.m
to nine and then from nine to five it's
the kids thing i like that compromise
you know i mean it's like you see
somebody on the machinery or how many
more you got
yeah yeah so the kids be like yo how
many slides do you got
and then you see all these buff guys
going on the slide like all right my
turn when's recess
over kid i'm with i'm with tifto because
uh so we have a little park in our
little community
and then me and taiko are playing those
just us two and then i see this guy
coming on a bike
and then there's like these monkey bar
things he comes in
and then it was like right in the way
where tycho was playing and he was like
doing pull-ups
and then i'm like oh this is kind of
weird i'm like well i guess they could
both use it you didn't just kick him i
would have kicked him
i didn't kick him but then i was like uh
based off
him kick him these pull-ups aren't
working anyways
so i'm like i don't even know what
you're doing here you guys just play
play with it
yeah wow so i ended up uh
i'm like oh because uh taika wanted to
play where the the jungle
gym thing was so i just moved him over
to where the slide was so we played over
there but then it did feel
weird seeing another adult like it's
almost like
when when the kid is there first that's
his territory right
so it seems weird to see an adult go
into a kid's
area put his kickstand down and then
he's also one of those guys that has a
helmet and a little uh
mirror on the side oh what the hell he's
a geek jesus how many pull-ups could he
do he's the kind of guy that can only do
three
but i'm like you know like 98 pounds i'm
brought up it's like
adults let kids have kind of like the
right way right away so yeah so
like seeing him come in and then seeing
where tycho was playing and he's like
he's like i need to use this while he's
doing a [ __ ] pull-up go over just
wow [ __ ] kick your stomach that's
good form oh yeah that's good
you impressed nick so like as a fitness
person right
and having to be at the park sometimes
yeah it's like
who the [ __ ] what fitness professional
is training their clients on the [ __ ]
jungle gym anyway
and if you are you're probably not that
good of a trainer like what are you
doing like
you could there's all you could get trx
bands you could attach that to a [ __ ]
fence like
i think you get your own goddamn
dumbbells like where are you training
your clients to do pull-ups
trying to hit the latissimus dorsi
you get the trx you get the rose you
know you get the gymnastic handles like
but you gotta you gotta get your body
ready for real world situations which is
why the twisty slide is my favorite
yeah it's functional fitness you know
what i mean
but it's like yeah like when you see a
kid at the playground
you the kid gets right away you know i
mean it's 10 a.m
but it's like what i i'm just very
curious to see what kind of exercises
i think guys i think it's the pull-up
guys
yeah it seems like it's male 1 pull-up
guys there's also like separate pull-up
bars that they have
that that's not on the yeah but it's the
it's the horsey guys
yeah yeah oh my bad yeah yeah yeah like
they're doing that yeah
yeah and then there's the merry-go-round
guys the you know you have to say they
spin
and they stay on for as long as they can
and then yeah you have all your friends
and then you go i'm ready one two three
you [ __ ] jump on
you know fly right off yeah and then the
swing guys you know the [ __ ] swing
guys
that's me that's me yes and at the end
you [ __ ] fly
yeah yeah that's the kind of functional
workouts people working on great
workouts yeah here's some pictures of
new york
city pull up guys i [ __ ] know that
guy he's not even dressed appropriately
he's in jeans bro get out of here
not really you're you're you're not
doing it right he's trying to he's
trying to just like
get flexed so he can impress somebody
real quick what is she doing there yeah
what's going on
those are the trx bands that's what you
could attach but you could attach that
anywhere damn people are people are
desperate huh yeah so this is
i think this picture it kind of shows it
properly here's a kid here kind of
staring at this person like
missing my playground what happened and
then she's kind of like
wait okay so you're not a kid in the
beginning you said
that they both both sides have like a
reasonable argument yeah i still don't
understand what the
argument is for them like their argument
is probably like
hey let's share the space but i think
what they don't understand is
having an adult there ruins the vibes
for the kids like the kid can't be in
their imagination world when you have
someone like just
working out on the side but the whole
point is right she has a trx band you
could attach that
[ __ ] anywhere it doesn't have to be
on the playground attach it to the floor
look at the post office truck
and pull that thing exactly talk about
you know car roads
i propose a compromise the fitness
people
have to be a part of the playground now
so if the kid right there
wants to get like somebody to help them
like when they jump
and then the adult has to go like this
then they could get a workout
and then they're a part of the they're a
part of the
big moms or something moms are strong as
[ __ ] yeah the kids are the dumbbells
that's a good thing all right i'm gonna
jump now and then the [ __ ] fitness
guy goes our god true and then he
[ __ ] runs over and the kid's like
dad and the [ __ ] guy catches up got
you
i don't want that kid being touched by
some strangers there has to be
background checks so we have to go
through that it's like the new uber you
know it's like that's what they have to
do
that's okay i'm okay you don't want
random strangers touching your kid
what's up with that like what's the
problem with that
oh yeah that's actually one of the
arguments too especially in cove at
times a lot of parents
are upset like pedophiles too uh
they don't really bring it up in this
article but uh covet times a lot of
parents are concerned about
sweaty people breathing hard at the gym
and like i guess some people don't
necessarily wipe down and you know like
when you're at the gym
these days the etiquette is to wipe down
everything after you're done using it
right
and people aren't necessarily doing that
at these playgrounds so that is a big
cause for concern
on the flip side a lot of the the
athletes the athletes the uh the fitness
people
they're you know they're saying like hey
i'm really courteous you know i'm coming
here because my gym is closed down
uh i don't have a place to work out i
come here uh
work out by myself i find a corner to do
this stuff so
there obviously there's some bad actors
here some people that come in and just
take over the playground
and i think most of them though are very
courteous and if a kid comes in
courteous then don't come at a time when
there's kids that's how courteous you
can be
don't [ __ ] don't show up and there's
kids in vienna i saw this
really sick ass park right like it
looked like a
straight up fortress in a tree house and
i was just eyeballing that [ __ ] and i
was like
man i wish i was a kid right now because
i so want to play
and then i i look around and it was just
a bunch of like you know moms and kids
and i'm like man after lunch i'm gonna
come back here yeah in europe they have
the
dome they have some really cool parks
right barcelona there was one like that
was like that i went back at night
you did go back in at night yeah you're
not because i got really weird
like same concept right i feel weird
about like
adults and kids and then me just being
this dude running around and being like
hey you want to [ __ ] play
even though it's like really dope yeah
to me it's the same policy as like let's
say you're on a
subway station and then there's a
pregnant lady standing up like you stand
up give up your seat
you know like some people have priority
so if i went to a playground
and i i was also stuck during the
quarantine period and then i don't have
a pull-up bar at home so i did do
pull-ups at the local playground
but as soon as i saw kids then i just
left yeah but what if you want to play
too
that's fine that is that is definitely
that's all okay but that's okay
you make your own kids so you see i'll
make kids i'll just borrow a kid to
pretend
so i can actually play i'll let you
borrow my kid there's something
something wrong with that but okay
yeah this is kind of like the chuck e
cheese rule then it's like you know
yeah in order to get in the chucky
cheese out to bring a child with you
unless you want to get pizza to go which
is the best bet oh yeah really good
pizza
but like i work out with my buddies at
the park because we don't have a gym is
that you cause working out yeah cause
because bart banned me from barbell
brigade but
i work out at the park and we we don't
we're not on the playground we find a
little separate space
yeah and we just work out over there
because i don't want a bunch of kids
running through
buy me anywhere yeah dude and not we're
we're
cussing we're saying stupid stuff you
know there are a lot of parks that
actually build out
equipment meant for exercise that is
away from the
the actual playground part too so fine
go find another part yeah they have this
machine
yeah they have the they have this
machine or like the
machine yeah you could go to the section
where the wuhan crew is practicing tai
chi
oh yeah you know
they should just go to like mcdonald's
play pens yeah that was so nasty
you catch corona and that [ __ ]
or you just gonna barbarous
yeah just go to barbara brigade yeah
opening in new york soon no kids allowed
in there yeah
[Music]
you